[Music]
the global beauty and cosmetics market
is expected to increase to more than
eight hundred billion dollars by 2023
that's up from about five hundred and
thirty two billion dollars in 2027 2017
now major companies including L'Oreal
Procter and Gamble and Neutrogena are
bringing technology and beauty together
with new products aimed at wellness
Sharon Profis is an executive editor and
producer with our partners at C net and
is here with the emerging trends you
came with your own bag of goodies today
I've noticed what you're wearing it's
called my skin Trac UV and it measures
your body's exposure to certain elements
how does it work yeah so this device
made by La Roche Posay
it has a little iris if you can see that
where the Sun comes and it's measuring
how much exposure you're actually
getting you then transfer that to an app
by just tapping your phone to this
device and when you're doing that it's
actually also charging the device so it
never needs to be charged what's the
difference between that and just wearing
sunscreen if you wear sunscreen every
single day you're judicious you reapply
every two hours which is the part that
people miss then maybe you don't really
need this I like that I'm someone who's
had skin cancer I think that's that's a
great device I also like that toothbrush
that you've got there I know it's
described as a Roomba for the mouth what
makes it so unique and feel effective
that Sharon's description pretty good
map's your room and make sure it doesn't
miss any spots so this toothbrush is
mapping your mouth using artificial
intelligence and lets you know if you're
missing any spots I know whenever I go
to the dentist he's like you're missing
your back teeth maybe I'd know if I had
those is it missing because he it just
maps the actual area or that it takes a
reading of whatever's in your mouth
plaque food and otherwise and then
targets that okay you should create that
product this is only mapping it and
making sure you're spending enough time
brushing your teeth too but this is the
thing Sharon now do I I've been brushing
my teeth for all these years now do I
need to go look at an app to see how
well I'm doing do I need to go look at
an app to see how much Sun does it it
seems like a pain in the butt to do but
you're saying what about that eye I
agree with that I think that eventually
what will happen
instead of using apps just like with the
smart home what we'll do is we'll ask
our device hey Siri or hey Google how
much sun exposure have I had today and
I'll let you know so you don't miss that
stuff but you're right the app is clunky
blame this device it's called clear up
it's for sinus pain relief how does that
work
yeah this is a break you were doing
that's right I was testing it out so
what this device does is it uses
microcurrent technology which is very
weak very low electrical stimulation
exponentially lower than a light bulb
for example and it's targeting the
nerves around your sinuses to relieve
pain so right now it's FDA cleared for
the pain relief related to rhinitis or
allergies so it's giving you a facial
and it's helping you with your size
right microcurrent is is available in
estheticians offices and apparently it
also don't you check products your big
huh it is I really do think that this is
a year for health tech products we're
seeing a lot of traditional companies
invest in this area of wellness I decide
from following you on CNET and getting
all of your advice how do we make sure
some of these products are worth it
because they're not cheap well that's
how you do it we have to test it out and
this product is on the market but most
of these are coming out later this year
so we'll try it and let you know I
wanted to follow you I want that I do
that okay thank you